why is thinking bad
I don't think thinking is bad I just
think it's overdone
you know we just we think all the time
all the time all the time you know I had
trouble sleeping last night because of
something that's coming up that you know
that is a bit of a problem for me and
I'm gonna have to figure out how to
handle it in a you know good way
so I started thinking as I'm thinking
and I'm thinking and I'm thinking and
I'm thinking and I'm going oh my God I'm
Drive self crazy with thinking that I'm
going nowhere with this thinking it's
just worrying so
too much thinking worry how much do we
worry all of that worry is useless
thinking
how much do we think about the past oh
listen did I say that was that okay I
don't know what happened yesterday with
that woman I don't know you know we
think about the past we think about the
future
those they don't exist there is no past
it happened it's done there is no future
it hasn't happened yet it's going to be
born out of your actions right now
so we're going to think it's a beautiful
tool we're Spiritual Beings embodies
and we're here to have an experience and
we have these Fantastic Tools like
thinking which is overused and tasting
and smelling and hearing and feeling and
touching and hands that can play
instruments you know it's all pretty
much a miracle if you allow yourself to
look at that way but thinking is taken
over and thinking thinking it's taken
over because there's so much noise you
know we want to think about these reels
I just get a little shot of Serotonin or
dopamine or whatever these reels are
giving me and think about what it'd be
like if I had 800 000 people following
me I don't know what they're thinking
about but it's you know it's overused
too much thinking it's not a bad thing
but it's way over use probably we should
probably be thinking 25
percent of what we're seeing thinking
the rest of the time we should be being
in a space in the moment
finding yourself in the moment and
that's another thing as you find
yourself in the moment and you're able
through meditation to kind of create
space and just be where human beings
who've forgotten how to be but when we
can create space and just be that's
where inspiration comes in that's where
things come out of the sky and I'm not
outside out of The Ether out of the
ethos and I believe this is a
communication from outside ourselves to
lead artists
you know we get hits and we get
Inspirations to lead artists to lead
Humanity because artists lead Humanity
so that doesn't happen when you're
thinking the ego is think the ego loves
to think they think about this I think
he likes me I think she's nasty I think
I'm gonna you know I'm thinking thinking
thinking it's it's uh it's too much
actually the ego is thinking because
they're terrified that we are going to
show up
in our power and take over
which I believe is what's happening I
believe Consciousness is rising very
very quickly and the reason that the
planet feels so Rocky is because the
darkness is right just as quickly it's
all happening very quickly you know kind
of like a race and all we can do
is be ourselves be ourselves and raise
our vibrational level with joy with
gratitude there are definite ways that
you can make yourself feel better and in
that this is what I think artists I
think you know artists think they're
their talent they think by the way they
think they're their talent
and they get very unhappy with me
because I say you're not your talent
they don't like that much I say your
talent or your the reason of your
Talent is your sensitivity
artists vibrate at a high they're very
sensitive and they vibrate at a very
high frequency and it is in that
frequency that they receive you know
Michelangelo what's in the marble let's
see I'll take that away in that way in
that way and I don't know if you've ever
seen the David
but
it it just thinking about it it takes
your breath away that a human being
created that
that comes from the ethos that's your
higher consciousness
talking to you
I think you talked about in the book
that with the higher frequency it can
have a flip side as well so we've seen
let's say a van Gogh or something where
the artist can go to a dark side which
can be very detrimental yeah and that's
something that we have to watch as
sensitive people yeah yeah and how does
he get to the dark side
thinking what do you think was on Van
Gogh's mind
it's a lot of thinking going on I'm not
good enough I'm too I'm not I can't I
don't fit in I don't you know if you
just give people the grace
of just being of just stilling
themselves
you know Stillness
extraordinary just the bounce if I just
do that for one second like that you see
the balance of the I don't know maybe he
likes me maybe he doesn't like me maybe
I should call maybe I shouldn't call
Maybe
maybe there's something on my email
maybe there's not did they email me I
don't know
you know just
being practice Stillness practice
breathing into your heart what I never
say his name right but I'm going to say
it anyway
brought you
Shin or mindfulness to the to the West
you know he says
I breathe in
I know that I am breathing in
I breathe out
I know that I am breathing out
that's it
this is such a gift to self
five minutes
and it's a gift itself because it's a
gift to you as a spiritual being not
thinking and not your future or not your
past or not any just be here now
five minutes a day and you won't by the
way you're thinking we'll come in and go
I think that you know
that's okay it's not bad you just go oh
thinking just note it go back to
breathing that's the practice it's like
flexing a muscle there is no wrong way
to meditate you know I didn't I didn't
want to meditate I have a busy mind and
I thought I'll be terrible at it I don't
like to do things I'm terrible at I'm
you know I'm sure meditation's great but
I'm you know I'm I'm not gonna be good
at that
but then I had to I felt I had to I had
a high blood pressure thing you know
they said oh your blood pressure so I
got to take medications you know and I'm
like no I'm not taking your medications
I'm very no medications thank you
um so I thought I'll do it with diet and
and try diet and meditation and I didn't
went down to normal so I took a class
you know in mindfulness it was wonderful
and I realized oh
that's how you Flex the muscle you're
breathing I breathe in I know that I'm
breathing out and I breathe out I know
that I'm breathing out and then I'm
thinking oh okay I'm thinking just note
it and go back to breathing just note it
that's how you teach yourself to create
space that's a thinking space this is a
being space two very different things
thank you space Oh I'm thinking you
don't even have to touch it oh okay I'm
thinking I think I'll have a Heyday with
this thinking I'm gonna go right on you
know with this thinking I like it or oh
I'm being
I needed a break from all that thinking
I'm hoping we can talk about Soul speak
I think in your book you talk about
mental chatter and when we have mental
chatter we enter a space where we can't
hear Soul speak
yeah what is that well this is what I
was just really talking about
um
you know they're different languages on
the planet we're just like we're
obsessed with thinking we're obsessed
with English we're obsessed with
language you know and English you know
Americans don't even learn other
languages because yeah we got this good
language I can't be bothered they all
need to learn to speak English anyway or
whatever it is but you know we were
obsessed with language language is a
wonderful tool but like thinking it's
it's way
over
you know you you know it's too too much
too much talking so
you know I talk about these things I
hope that they're interesting to you but
you know there's you can have
communication with trees and you can
have communication with rocks and you
can have communication with the ocean
and you can have communication with sky
and you can have communication with
animals people understand that you know
they have deep really loving wonderful
Communications with their animals you
can do the same thing with any life form
on the planet and
you know that that alone
if you have to listen for your energy
exchange with a tree
you know then you're able to listen to
the counsel of your own heart
which is really your higher
Consciousness which is really all
Consciousness you know we're all the
same we're all expressions of the
universe it's very clever the Universe I
don't know of all these people and it's
they're all going to have different
reflections of me and going to give them
all the same tools and go
and then you know the person you know
would lives in a matrix you know they
they think and they create their life
you're doing it so if you're doing it
gone East you can just as well turn the
corner and go west with your own
thinking and your own actions and your
own desires
um
so the question was Soul speak how do
you listen to your soul
you know that happens in Stillness but
it also happens by accepting the fact
that it's a different language
it's you know thinking is in English you
don't think you know in anything but
English
you know all your thoughts are like you
know they're language thoughts
um listening to your soul is not a
language it's an energy exchange like
with trees
you know
when when I was little you know I was I
was really lonely
um so did I talk about the fact that you
know I I had parents and they were
artists but they kind of just put you on
the planet and said go and there wasn't
really a lot of um you know hugging or
cherishing cherishing is such a
beautiful word that we should cherish
each other like a husband and wife
cherish each other what does that mean
that means that you're going to practice
kindness that means you're going to
practice the Gratitude of having that
person in your life that's what
cherishing is so I don't I don't
remember that being a child and I I
really thought it should be there you
know I had a lot of ideas of what a
parent should be and you know people
should listen to me and acknowledge me
and you know I had these ideas and it
wasn't getting I I wasn't doing well
with people it wasn't in love people I
didn't find them authentic but I lived
in the woods we lived we had Woods
surrounding us so I would just go to the
woods all day and you know
it's like being in a Disney movie I mean
sometimes I think you know you sound
like Disney it's awesome but I don't
care it's true you know I had
relationships with trees and this one
was you know female and this one was
male and this one I talked to about
certain things and this one not and that
one I didn't really have a relationship
with and that one I had something went
wrong with that one I don't want to go
over there it scares me you know I was
working with energy fields and very
communicative and I felt they raised me
I had certain trees that I really took
counsel from now what does that mean I
mean did they speak to me no but they
it's like having a chiropractic
adjustment they would I would maybe ask
questions of the tree or I would look to
the tree with my energy field of I am
unhappy and lost and the tree would send
back something to my heart that was so
soothing it's okay we're here
and so that was kind of my natural state
with things and then one day I realized
I could communicate a little more
because you know I was going to school
and it was my birthday was coming up and
I felt very
on uh birthday asked I think this was
going to be kind of a celebration of my
dreams
which would just be for somebody to see
me and go Hi how are you what are you
doing here what do you want to do you
know
um I see you I see that you're special I
see you've come for a reason so I was
feeling very sorry for myself and I was
going I just don't get it I don't get
why they don't see me I mean I came here
I thought you know I would make my
parents happy I should see that joy in
their eyes you know where's the joy in
the eyes you know they just look kind of
worried to me I I don't get it and I
heard this was not language but the
closest thing a concept concept and this
artist worked with Concept all the time
the thing comes in not as language it
comes in as concept and how do you know
it's concept because it hits your heart
something moves in you and you go what
and it came in you know we're here and
we might just have to be enough
and I would
you know okay that's good I it would be
nice to have a third dimensional person
somewhere down the line you know but I
heard it loud and cleared and from that
time on I could kind of get around and
feel like okay this is my place
my place is these kinds of
communications and then later in life it
was to pass those gifts on or those
Concepts to others who might enjoy them
you know I knew there were going to be
lots of them going
foreign
that's fine
that's fine you you can't be responsible
for people's response you can only be
responsible for your intention and what
you offer as a human being